uh this is the 60-second annual Hume
lecture
um so great prestigious event each year
the annual lecture in honor of Dr Edward
H Hume which is made possible by the
generosity of his family and many
friends as you may know Dr Hume devoted
his long career to working in China and
elsewhere in the cause of Health Care
and medical training he graduated from
Yale College back in 1897 and received a
medical degree four years later from
Johns Hopkins
Dr Hume worked in India from 1903 to
1905 before going to China where he
founded the shanya school of medicine
and the shanghya hospital
previously known as the Shanghai medical
school Under the auspices of Yale China
Association in Changsha
Dr Hume also served as the president of
the colleges of Yale in China in the
1920s
he returned to the United States but was
recalled back to China in 34 and worked
for several years in Health
Administration in liaison with the
Chinese National Health Administration
from 1937 until his retirement he
directed the Christian medical Council
for overseas work in New York City
shortly after his death in 1957 funds
from colleagues friends and family
enable the establishment of this
lectureship to bring to Yale eminent
Scholars of East Asian studies
and we have one such eminent scholar
here today who were very pleased and
delighted to welcome
Professor nicholasando is Professor of
Synology at KU Levin in Belgian
and a member of the Royal Academy of
Sciences and arts of Belgium he took his
PhD from Leiden University in 1984 and
has spent the years since then teaching
mainly in Flemish and dutch-speaking
countries with the occasional foray into
China and North America
Professor stonder has produced a decade
of monographs numerous co-written or
co-edited volumes and he's made great
contributions to the field also with
volumes like the handbook of
Christianity in China those two thick
volumes that sit in all of our research
libraries
his own major research focus is cultural
contacts between China and Europe in the
17th and the 18th centuries
his work is on the history of books
people and ideas that crossed between
China and Europe he writes and reads
extraordinarily well on both sides of
that divide so a work like his Chinese
voices in the right controversy analyzes
the Chinese end of a story that we often
hear from European perspectives while
his latest book the Chinese Gazette in
European sources joining the global
public in the early and mid Qing Dynasty
looks from the opposite end of the
viewfinder at European reception
The Arc of his work began with yangting
Yoon thinking about his influence on
the influence of Confucian and Buddhist
ideas on Christian thinking in that
period in the 17th century then he
worked through works on a particular
object or book and more recently
multiple projects on rituality visual
culture historiography and print culture
his books are exquisitely produced for
example the Chinese voices in the rights
controversy has a whole series of
wonderful reproductions of Chinese texts
in color and some of them fold out in in
full form
um both in keeping with his research
interests and also I suspect by dint of
being a Jesuit and having access to nice
presses
we were discussing uh at work at
lunchtime today uh his work only dance
after uh Joseph
um again uh how dance is a moral
National interest in China in early
China and how the pauses and the
silences are ritually important too and
again you can see all these wonderful
illustrations of dance figures
throughout the work
Professor standard has not only given
great service to the field in his books
but also in other aspects he curates the
EU China list email list that many of us
receive details every few days of new
articles and new books produced in this
field
he's also been a curriculum innovator
creating service courses throughout
Belgium
it's a super Delight to have you here
speaking to us today and we're looking
forward to your lecture on the
interconnected history of the Chinese
Gazette in the 18th century welcome
foreign
thank you very much for this very kind
introduction I'm delighted to be here
and very honored also to be here
um I also thank the the foundation to
support this visit and also the center
to welcome me I'm coming from a food
culture and a gift culture so I also
brought chocolate
Easter eggs so during the break at the
end you can take them and make sure that
at the end of the reception nothing is
left over I'm not going to carrying them
home
um let me immediately start with
the talk looking at China from the
periphery the interconnected history of
Chinese Gazette in the 18th century and
I first start with a bit a personal note
you already referred to it so the my
main interest in research is this very
simple question what happens when two
cultures meet each other
uh when I was taking my Synology classes
in Laden I had some courses in
anthropology and that was all about
contact between cultures that was a
specialty also in Laden and I was
fascinating by that fascinated by that
topic and I also had the chance to have
a circle as a professor
was also the Hume lecturer in 2003 so
that's more than 20 years ago and
Professor trucker is known for his
studies on Buddhism in China
but also on Christianity in China
basically he had two books and 60
articles and half of them are on
Buddhism and half on Christianity
and its major question was what happens
when Buddhism arrived in China and how
was it transformed by Chinese Society
though the title does not really sound
like that at the budget conquest of
China in fact he was approaching the
question from the other side and having
studied that subject he was wondering
what happened with an other minority
religion like Christianity in China in
the 17th century so I attended a seminar
and then he encouraged me to pursue that
that topic so that's a bit the origin of
my research and in one of the interviews
he gave people asked him but why why do
you study this question and also
Christianity in China and he answered I
believe that Chinese culture shows its
features most clearly when it is
confronted with something from outside
it's like people in Conflict when you're
acquiring with your knee paper you may
say things and show things about your
character that you otherwise never would
in the same way the Chinese have shown
certain characteristic features in their
reactions to Buddhism and Christianity
so it's major yeah concern was yeah I
want to understand China as a synologist
and that's also my primary interest
through an intercontact between cultures
and to give my yeah to put that in a
larger context because I put as a title
looking at China from the periphery I
think about 10 years ago we made a major
invention in the photography history
because we invented a selfie
and by inventing the selfie we created
the illusion that we no longer need
something that was essential for for
photography namely that it was always
the other
who made a picture of myself and now we
think that when we take a picture of
ourselves we only need ourselves and
that's a kind of challenge I think for
history how can and that relates to the
sentence of of Turk also how can maybe
it's not the only way but how can also
out like looks or out like sources and
tell something about China
um and this is related to a concept of
interaction
on which yeah I'm doing further research
at this moment I just do a small let's
say theoretical break on this in between
us so if you would ask me what is my
vision on Intercultural history
and I take the case of the 17th 18th
century to put it very general you have
the Chinese you have to inter Europeans
and they interact and then there is a
kind of text
mathematics and then we wonder is this
now Chinese is this European whereas
what I'm interested in is that in fact
this is an result of an interaction and
an in-betweenness and any in-betweeners
can lead to a story
just like in this meeting we meet this
is a kind of interaction and after that
at the reception you can start to tell a
story or your question and you send the
email to someone or I will tell
something to others how was it and so on
it's always a story and and this is or
can be expressed in new cultural
Creations such as text images artifacts
buildings but also in rituals
communities Concepts now as historians
we have access to these cultural
creations
and to a certain extent maybe our dream
is also to get some sense through the
story of the original in-betweeners or
the interaction that took place
but it's even more important is that the
same interaction is also between our
documents and the way how we look at
them so this is a little bit the frame
in which I try to reflect but now I will
only focus on two aspects of it
namely first looking at the culture from
the periphery this is nothing original I
think for instance at Fudan University
you have this institute for higher
Advanced humanistic studies and that's
one also of the teams
so on the basis of written material
other views what is said about Chinese
history for instance and the whole idea
expressed by several Scholars also here
at the University here about
interconnected cultural history
so what will be my case my case will be
the Chinese gusset
uh and as you can see this is a drawing
of a photography not but a drawing by an
Italian
who made the drawing of this counselor
and this is the only image that is still
preserved and you can see here the other
wall makes the picture of this person
so this latest book also to involve a
little bit my personal history I'm I
have a project on a print in 17th and
18th century because when the
missionaries arrived in China unlike in
Latin America in India in the
Philippines and so on there was an
active printing culture in China and not
only Matthew Richie says that it is
cheaper faster and more efficient than
in Europe but there was no pre-printing
censorship so they immediately could
publish what they what they wanted
within this context I was raising the
simple question did the missionaries
also read The Gazette I come back on The
Gazette the official say the official
newspaper and with official decisions
and I had hoped to spend maybe two weeks
on this topic because I said well there
will be not so much material about it
and I spent three years on it
so this was a kind of serendipity
and then kofit came so I had occasion to
work a bit harder to produce a book and
this covet also affected one of uh
maurya who is sitting there because she
had a scholarship for Yale and she could
not leave for Yale and now she is here
but her state was delighted and when she
told her that I said well you come and
work for me and you will help me and so
this book is also partly with a great
help of a molga by criticizing my text
um so we are I will focus on this
Gazette and what is a Gazette is a
publicly available government
Gazette that was distributed and sold
in print and sometimes also in
manuscripts and generally it is called
Depot or tropo or sometimes also a Ting
pong or let's say in Western literature
it's most often known as king Pao the
painting Gazette now since the 19th
there have been a number of Publications
on this topic mainly also by Chinese
Scholars you'll find here the references
and Macross in one of her articles she
mentions or in a dissertation she
mentions there are three ways in which
the Gazette is studied history of the
press or history of the state or history
of the information in China and there
here are three examples of these
approaches
treated this topic among her work in the
in the context of a newspaper and so and
then you link it to newspaper Hilda
dubert on the distribution of
information in the sun Dynasty and in my
democras as recently this book where the
link with the state is made
uh and for the period after 1800
the information is quite extensive and
also in English because
quite a number of missionaries
translated these Chinese Ching Pao into
English and there is a whole database on
it by Brill and also the reader that is
published also by brill now what is the
problem the problem is that
hardly any Chinese gazettes are
preserved from before 1800s
basically
for instance for the Chen long period
and that's 60 years you only have 394
gazettes which means 394 days
which means more or less one year and a
half
text so to compare that with Europe were
the newspapers or what we call
newspapers
existed since the end of the 16th in
fact the early 17th century since the
1720s yeah you have quite a extensive
documentation versions of gazettes of
the late 17th century and so on
uh here you have also from The Young Jun
period and that's called tipaw but that
is in fact not an original cassette and
it's the title that is used used later
to put it and to make it as a reference
but it's not an original original text
so what is then the next problem is that
most Scholars will use the name kingpal
baking asset and also the structure and
so on of The Gazette after 1800 for what
is before
uh one solution is to check
for references in Chinese Diaries
notebooks novels as for instance Hilda
the weird as done with other people as
well
so my simple question was then can we
find some references about the pre-1800
Gazette in this periphery namely in
European or as I will referred to in a
Korean sources this was not completely
new because there are two other Scholars
who briefly have done some risk research
for that especially knee Yoko for the
amnio period
so what will be my
basic statement doing this talk so
regarding looking at the culture from
the periphery you I will try to convince
you that indeed Europeans sources expand
our knowledge on the cassette before
1800 and this regarding to the structure
the content and so on
and moreover that they inform us about
how Europeans
[Music]
and also as Global agents informed
Europe about the Gazette
and then the next step will be a kind of
interconnected history namely that if we
looked and use all kind of digital
databases we can discover how this
translated versions of The Gazette also
were received for instance by
Enlightenment thinkers and developed
helped to develop their thought about
not only about China but about European
politics
so that will be my major statement
now I had to solve a first problem
um namely when I saw translations or
quotations from the cassette was to
verify whether
um these were correct statements was
this invented by the missionaries but or
was this really can that be fountainic
acid so you have the Gazette and then
you have the Western manuscript and then
you have the printed text that the
problem is that these gussets except for
eight copies are no longer preserved
so what did I do
I took a sideway and I first tried to
find
the
references in the shalu
but the shalu is not the origin of The
Gazette because the shalu was often
compared later than the Gazette was
let's say it was printed within or
distributed within a month after the
event took place in the palace
so but on the basis of the shalu I could
identify the same passages in the chi
Juju or in the shanghyu the edicts by
the emperor and they were
a much closer reliable source to what
was taken over in The Gazette because
what happened at the court the decisions
were then written and then put on a
board and then people copied them and
then they were printed
so to make this concrete this is a
manuscript and there you will uh you
will see I can see but here the text
here and there it's written c one
Whatever
Sam mil and so on so I see this figure
and then I try to find in the
Academia the scripta cineica database in
the shalu
if I can identify that and indeed here
you have this figure here and I can
identify this name in the French
transcription of the 17th or the 18th
century and so on
and then on the basis of this this is
the chichijou and these are the original
edicts
and the same here with the passage about
the oppression and the Finnish version
and I could identify the sources
so just like the collection in Brill for
the Post 1800 at the reader and so Brill
asked me to include it and in the in my
book I have about 60 Pages
identifying more than 300 items of that
were translated in one or another text
in European text and that can be linked
to original events and that you always
can can check
um
so what I shall do now I in my book I
discuss the country period Then the
young John period and then the channel
period I will focus on the yongchang
period which is most interesting in
terms of the interaction
and let us start with the production
uh the printed sources what are the most
important printed sources the first
appears in the literally different e
curious which is a major collection in
Europe in the in the 18th century with
34 volumes and in it you can find three
letters in total more than 300 Pages by
a certain missionary Circle tonsa it's
not known at all it has no text in
Chinese he hardly at any other letters
but it has D3 letters that are
completely devoted to the cassette
and he arrived in China in 1701 he spent
seven years in baking and then it was in
Exile in Canton and that's where he did
the work he came back to Europe he
worked with duhalda on description the
machine and then he left back to China
but he died on the way
now in this text he gives
information about the content of The
Gazette and he says well you have the
names of the officials criminal cases
admonitions rituals laws and so on when
you look at this list and you compare
that with descriptions today in Chinese
or in Western sources about the Gazette
it's very very similar and so we had a
good understanding of what was the
Gazette
and I did the same work I come back on
this text later
which of course is letters and you can
see here again the case this is a yo but
that's the French translation
transcription
in the 17th century
um
to give an example of what kind of
events is
translated and reported here you have
overview the morning and installation of
the new Empress Memorial Archway the
rescue of people in years of bad harvest
the relief of the poor a death sentence
and so on so as you can see these topics
are not related to Christianity
and in the 300 Pages he hardly has any
references to crisp Christianity in an
explicit way
next he gives information about the
structure and the form of the
um
of the cassette and here you can see the
memorials the answers by the emperor the
instructions of the emperor other
memorials as one and he also adds that
they contain more or 6 60 to 70 pages
and that's a little bit of a problem but
that can be solved in one way or another
um
do we have a Gazette of the young Jung
period well this is in my eyes the only
copy that is left
or that I could identify and this can be
found in the First
National bibiotic in Vienna
and as you can see the title
you'll find it here
and you have the structure of the
cassette and then first decisions here
and then it continues and you have the
different departments so it's this has
the whole structure
now why
is this probably the only copy left and
moreover is this the name of the Gazette
at that time
I checked in plenty of databases on Tito
Tran Lu and I could not find any
reference in a Chinese database
only
in Korean databases and Korean databases
of this
are the reports of the delegations that
annually from Korea went to China
and there you have a reports and
quotations from The Gazette and they
said oh today we read this and this in
the detox
moreover they add in one of these
settings and this is the same as our
child Paul so they really make this link
maybe we have a second copy left and
that's in this box here so that's in the
museum in
a museum
in Paris and they have a collection of
stones and of
mineral collection
and
most probably these minerals are wrapped
in paper from the cassette I already
asked them yeah could we open it but
they still have to discuss that
but I have to convince them because they
may have the second copy of Gazette in
the world
silver
now so you wonder yeah but this is not
Ting Paul or this is not typo so there
was already a very important article in
1992 in one Wu by uh
uh
saying that yeah we are always using
this term kingpal but ping pow is only
used since 1852
with a few exceptions before
and the term used in the shenong period
is the T tall
um
that's this here and here you have some
copies of the title shooting that are
preserved in Paris and of which we you
know that amyo he used it and he you
have the handwriting of a new in the in
the top
so what is the conclusion then
provisional conclusion of This research
is that yeah the identification of this
text of the title chuanlu that this is
kind of Forerunner of the Tito which
later then became the Ching Paul
and this is one of the examples how by
looking from the periphery you can
discover something about Chinese sources
you also know this text because here in
Yale there is this project in which I
don't know whether you look
you have the references to it and it was
also uh thanks to Martin Hydra with whom
I was in contact that he made me
attentive to the title uh shooting and
so that I also discovered them in uh in
Paris
so we go back to quota he also tells
something about the significance of the
cassette oh
so and this is a team that will come
back and back and he said they are very
useful instead of filling it as a dome
in certain parts of Europe with useless
things and slander and calumny in China
it only mentioned what's relates to the
emperor
in Europe we have newspapers with gossip
but in China this is reliable material
and that's why it can also be an
instruction for literhati and the people
and then he adds the following about
read the whole sentence because it's
important for what will follow nothing
is printed here which has not been
presented to the Emperor or which not
does not come from the Ember himself
those who take care of it would not dare
to add anything to it not even
uh their own Reflections under the
penalty of corporal punishment
last year two writers were sentenced to
death for having inserted in The Gazette
some circumstances which were false so
this is only one sentence in its 300
pages and I spent a lot of time to know
whether that was correct or not finally
I found the reference and indeed there
was a case that is mentioned also in the
shalu where the emperor had a meeting
with some of his counselors and
afterwards they went out on a boat in
the Summer Palace and they got drunk and
they were drinking wine and whatever and
they had a good feast and one two of
them two of these reporters in the show
Paul probably
mentioned
mentioned what happened
and then the emperor said no it's not
true because I never drink wine and
they were condemned to death
so we know that this was a real case
also
um there are also some personal
considerations concerning the Gazette
it's useful to a missionary
and he regrets that for years
I did not read the newspaper and now
when I'm in the South I see how
interesting thing is for religion and
laws and custom and language
and most of the missionaries don't do so
because the language is not enough or
they immediately the idea of associate
the idea of Gazette with the European
Gazette they imagine that it in which
one puts or has put everything one wants
good or bad without any distinction and
you see their view on European gazettes
in contrast with China
so this is a First Source 300 pages
Second Source
is Perroni and that is a person for a
robust procreator of propaganda fide and
he was also at the same time in Canton
so probably they also even work together
and he sends a yearly report to Rome for
the propaganda City and one finds them
in the archives of the propaganda
graffiti
uh what is interesting here is that we
have a transcript
of the whole text in Chinese that's
really unique on which we can we don't
have the original Gazette but we have
the transcript
um the content the form is very similar
to contasa the difference you can say is
that
contosa addresses it to the halda to be
widely spread Perroni it's only for the
propaganda fidi it was not published at
all what is unique is the presence of
this Chinese text
he also has some personal considerations
and what do you find yeah the same
references nor is there any danger that
the story will be altered by a passion
of the writer and
that happened that someone was two
people were condemned for it
now uh
both of them they mainly Translate
but in between
one will find some references with their
ID on the emperor and about the
bureaucratic system
so this is not a major topic maybe for
the first letter it is but not in the
other but it transpires and between the
translations one will find some few
sentences discussing that now what is
the general idea of contosa regarding
the emperor so despite the fact that
Christianity is persecuted and that
himself is in Exile it's a rather
auditory description of the emperor he
has a wise government service to the
public utility he uses really this
public utility which was a team also in
France an active bureaucracy
and with officials taking initiative
important to underscore that not all the
other Jesuits had the same opinion
because
they were much more critical and they
considerate despotic government and
absolute and feared master I come back
on that topic later
a fuel because on the one hand is
positive the emperor is good at
lecturing
he is attentive to the needs of the
people there is a bureaucracy that is
good communication with him and so on on
the other hand he expresses the ID that
the emperor is blinded by his officials
his speeches are disconnected from
reality the bureaucracy is perpetually
flattering and praising the emperor
so what do we learn from this production
you can see well that we already learned
something about the Gazette the
existence of the egg asset the form of
The Gazette the extent of it but also
something about the content that is
represented in these texts
so that's the first point I wanted to
make this is the presentation
let us now look at how were these texts
this information how was that
distributed
before looking at the reception by the
Enlightenment thinkers distribution in
the first place by academic journals so
at that time in France for instance
there were quite a number of academic
journals and what is typical for this
academic journals let's say academic or
intellectual or the Republic the the
letter is that
um they have book reviews but the book
reviews are not in the first place a
whole evaluation of a book but rather
consists of very large excerpts of the
text
and that's important because
they discuss the text by or let's say
they present the text by contosa and for
people who did not have access to
electricity curious in fact the
information of the about the gas I guess
it's three times because it were three
different volumes over a period of
nearly seven eight years
were produced in for instance juvenile
de server of memor
and one fight in them the same vision
the content the difference with European
uh Gazette and the vision on the emperor
you also have the newspapers or the
pamphlets for instance here the be
revived which is a a kind of pamphlet
that was only published during two or
three years based on the text that we
will see in a in a few minutes and in
which there is a whole description the
public asset is the reverse of our
European gassets which are medley of
Truth and falsehood and you see that
these points are repeated and the
reference again to these two writers
that were content
so these are newspapers journals also
some books description is an important
production for volumes edited by duhalda
and was edited twice in French in France
and in the Netherlands in English in
German later also in Russian and in it
one finds again a description of The
Gazette there is nothing inserted in the
cassette but what has reference to the
government
it's to direct and to instruct the
mandarins and the people
and again the reference in 1725 you had
this authors who were writers who were
condemned to that
because they spread false information
and we can look even further you have
[Music]
works on Chinese and world history one
of them is de Maya is
it's a remarkable work more than seven
thousand Pages 13 volumes
this is until today still the most
extensive work in any European language
based on Chinese and natural sources
written by one author we have of course
the Cambridge history of China
150 orders
I'm not sure that they just already has
13 volumes but these are nearly
translations or basically translations
of the the tradition
basically
and in it it is uh it is includes also
the young Jung period of which was not
yet written the history in the classical
Chinese history so they took all the
information from the letters of contosa
to write that part of history and other
works like the masi is
in which you also have a whole chapter
or whole part on the gassettes
so this is the distribution what could
we say about it
first I join yeah the idea of Jurgen
auster Hamill at this this famous book
on uh and febling the East
um
where we we can state or I can state
that you're possible informed about the
cassettes and about events in China
and austro Hamlet writes about this
aspect around the mid 18th century the
public in France in Germany was better
informed about China than about many
other countries in the Europe's
periphery and I find that the Quant uh
important statement but yeah you need
someone like Oster Hamilton who has more
or less read everything and don't make
such a statement but what is even more
important is that Austria Hamill makes a
clear let's say distinction between the
pre-1800 and post 1800 way in which uh
Europe speaks about the East so he
speaks about an inclusive eurocentrism
into an exclusive eurocentrism and in
the first period what you have is that
quite a number of authors make an
attempt
to let the east in this case China speak
on the basis of their own
voices or texts and you see that already
in duhalda and in other texts
this the the really make it explicit
they say we present translations of
course translations are always an
interpretation but we present a
translation because that's the best way
how you can understand China and it's
very few interpretations
so modern scholarship will focus Morely
on the misinterpretation of China by
these colors whereas maybe we have to
ReDiscover everything that was already
translated
at that time
so this was the distribution and so we
notice here that in fact the information
that was after all relatively limited
the three letters of contosa had a much
wider distribution in all kind of ways
in Europe so that Europe was informed
about gazettes but now what happened in
the interco interconnected history and
how did Enlightenment thinkers well
react or use or discuss the gusset
yeah
and we start with Voltaire
and here you see a quote from a text
that is entitled The gusset
a Lemma in a dictionary and that's in
the famous encyclic
and that is the famous Enlightenment
dictionary encyclopedi in which yeah
anyone working on enlightenment uses
that one of the the basic text in which
all the ideas were were integrated and
voltev writes the text on Gazette in
which he explains that The Gazette was
invented in Venice at the end of the
16th century or the beginning of the
17th century and that it is called
Gazette because of gazetta
which was a coin in Venice and you had
to pay that coin to have your one or two
pages or whatever of your newspaper
have been established in China from time
to Memorial in The Gazette of the Empire
is printed there every day by order of
the Court
and you see immediately it makes the
link to China and it's not very clear
what is meant by the memorial but at
least it's a long time
that it much longer than it happened in
in Europe he had some other commentaries
I've come back can come back on that but
the interpretation is quite difficult of
these other sentences
now the next question is then
Voltaire makes reference to it
but did he actually read the letters by
contosa
and there we have a very nice proof
because after
um voltaire's death his whole Library
moved to Saint Petersburg
by Katarina and
in the 1960s 70s when it was not easy to
do research in in Russia at least in the
protective research you had Russian
researchers going through all the
volumes and printing down all the
annotations by
um
by Voltaire to the volumes and so I
could check and indeed it has several
annotations in the letters concerning
the cassette and then you find them also
in my book you have the the paper slips
the references and this is what I
mentioned earlier and so here
uh
voltaire's right or this is the case of
this Mr chill
and in which he discusses in one of his
books so we know that he actually read
the cassettes he refers to it
indicates it in his most famous book is
which is a very very important book in
terms of History because it's the text
that booked China first in history and
it was a major Revolution because it's
not a Biblical text it's not ancient
Middle East or so it's a China that is
the most ancient country and in it
um
he writes then at the Journal of the
Chinese emperor the most authentic and
useful newspaper in the world since it
contains the details of all the public
needs resources and interests of all the
orders of the state
so he writes some other things but
that's uh but the most most important
now besides the fact that he mentions
The Gazette and that he admire Suga said
he also uses the information included in
the text by contosa
and also description of the machine to
discover its own ID of an ideal
government
so for him the new emperor yongchang
surpassed his father in the love of laws
and public good and these are all key
Notions and the love of laws that enters
in the French discussions and the public
good and no Emperor encouraged
agriculture more and this is the
physiocat who promoted the development
of Agriculture for economy
so he admires the role of the emperor
there is no in his eyes there is no
evidence of a despotic or arbitrary
government it is a monarch who governs
relying on subordinated administrative
boards
the officials were selected through
exams that was something uh
the Europeans were in fascinated by the
Chinese examination system
which of course did not exist in France
or in Germany or in England
and he also states that it's a listed
bit on Justice emerged in which virtue
is independent from religion that's this
one is this major statement in which
personal value was more important than
hereditary privileges as was the case in
France
so this is a first approach quite
positive admirative about the
text that he finds and proclaiming how a
government should be and how
France can take inspiration from the
Chinese case
not all the Enlightenment thinkers had
the same
opinion Montesquieu here we can also
prove that he read text about the
Gazette namely his annotations in
description
and he has a different opinion because
according to him it is a despotic state
it is a state with arbitrary power and
what is one of his arguments he writes
the author namely
praises the cassette of painting of
baking printed every day nothing is put
in it that has not been presented to the
emperor we have seen these sentences two
writers were punished with with that by
putting false circumstances the Judgment
of the tribunal was founded on the fact
that they had disrespected the emperor
which is a capital crime and then comes
the sentence by montesqui nothing is so
dangerous as these vague laws the
district respect is an arbitrary thing
so he will
interpret this sentence and they say
yeah that's a very nice example of
something that is very arbitrary who is
deciding on whether this is
not funded on facts or not
and so he is a
classification of China is a despotic
state
is a physio cat
and he has a text on despotism but we
will see that his interpretation is of
despotism is different from the one of
modes Q because for him China is a
country governed by legitimate despots
this is not an arbit Barbarian
government it's fundamental Constitution
was entirely independent from the
emperor so we explicitly makes reference
to the cassette it is a daily historical
instruction
and we find again the case of the two
writers
in his eyes the law in China permits the
practice of remonstration of the emperor
there is perhaps no country where the
Sovereign can be remonstrated with more
Liberty than in China so that's the
interpretation by genev
the final case now these were three
Enlightenment thinkers but at the same
time we have another very interesting
case namely the first uh
freedom of press and freedom of writing
act in the whole of Europe
which was voted in the Swedish
parliament in 1766.
and I could quote the text and also in
my own book
has shown in detail how the two members
of parliament were during several years
promoted
the this press act and finally it was
approved
what was one of their sources
was
description on the machine
and the reference to The Gazette
she writes the freedom of writing of the
present you can see that in the text and
the information had been in existence in
China since ancient times and that
contributed substantially to the wealth
and stability of China
in other words in Europe once said we
need a freedom of press act and our big
example is China
because there since long times
the freedom of press has contributed to
wealth stability
so to summarize this part on the
reception
Enlightenment thinkers base themselves
on the information from the cassettes
and they developed their own ideas on it
we have seen voltage of course I'm very
fast in the presentation these are
General presentations in the text of
course it's much more subtle is quite
positive modes Q is negative and the two
Swedish
members of parliament used it to promote
the freedom of the press
monster Hamill another quotation I like
that he mentions the objection that
China was idealized in
text which drew the information mainly
from description on the machine may be
correct but misses the point because
first this Chinese bureaucracy in the
first half of the 18th century was
indeed perhaps the best functioning in
the world
and its idealization was an
extrapolation from yeah a certain
reality because Europe even until today
does not have such a system
and second reports from the Middle
Kingdom gave
European theories the first opportunity
to come to grips in a detailed way with
the problems of administration in
government and you see how it functioned
here so here they are no longer
investigating The Gazette they are not
using it as a means to understand what
district has said but the Gazette is a
kind of mirror that they use I would say
not in the first place to understand
China but to develop their own ideas
that's the the interaction that happened
at that time and for us or let's say for
this topic what is interesting is that
this all happened by the fact that there
were some missionaries who decided that
maybe this information is important to
translate and send to Europe they never
thought so what happened with this
information
now very briefly just to give a taste of
what still can be read in the book
is the Chang lung period there you have
as major source Memoir concerned
15 volumes and then two volumes after
the French Revolution about 30 years
later 20 years later a very impressive
text with plenty of translations
and this was the result of an
interaction on initiative by hamaki
bertan who was the councilor of the
French King
and will bus for 30 years in
correspondence with missionaries in
Beijing and I mentioned here I'm your
and also Bourgeois we come back on him
you have the picture of amyo
and we should not forget that's very
important to underscore that all these
missionaries work together with Chinese
this was always a interaction a
collaboration and in the case of amio we
know the name of this Chinese and when
he died it was a kind of biography and a
commemoration of him also in the
remarkable
what is also important is that in the
1760s
1760s there were at least two Chinese
who spent I think eight or nine years in
in France in Paris
they entered the Jesuit Society there
but then the Jesuits were abolished and
but they remained priests and when they
returned or wanted to return to to China
Berta told them well I pay you for one
year to travel around in France and to
go and visit factories for porcelain and
for gobble and and so on and so on and
to discover the economy and and the
cultural aspect in France and then when
you go back to China you report a report
about the same topics to back to to
Europe
and so this this people and these these
two Chinese they have also plenty of
text in French
in the Memoir concert knowledge now in
it you have also a few hundred Pages
only on The Gazette and I select this
one because there is the reference to
the circle truancy
so in 19 in 1779
we have extensive reports on the
existence of the circle truances
[Music]
etc etc and
sober and a detailed description of it
and the the the the
Tito that I showed before
are under origin because at a certain
moment I'm using oh I will send you a
few copies and so that's why we have
them in Paris and you have the detailed
discussions on the Chen long
Emperor correcting or punishing some of
his sons because they made mistakes in
the transcription so because the emperor
regularly
called some volumes that were
transcribed of the circle of the Circle
Rancho and then he tried to find some
mistakes and then he sent he sent it
back and he said well here and there is
a whole system of punishment for every
character that you wrote wrongly
now what happened with this we have also
the notes by Berta
he was in regular contact with the
French King and here you have the the
quote uh
a
here
a lesson effect please
read and that's a passage that refers
also to The Secret Rancho so we know
that the French King was informed about
the secretary but what is even more is
that Berta wanted to acquire
a copy of the secretary
so here he writes to China this
collection would be a superb present to
make to our Europe which good does enjoy
all the Chinese literature please let me
know if it would be impossible to
acquire it transmitted and packaged at
Canton for example by making some gifts
of price to the emperor which may be
agreeable to him for example tapestries
God bless mirrors
so it's a very nice case how an advisor
to the French King
in the 18th century
informed about this major Book Project
in China and even though it did not know
one character of Chinese wanted to
acquire it where are the times where in
Europe today there is
a president or King who gets the advice
please can we have a Chinese database
because that's so important we are very
far from that times
uh just to finish with this here at beta
was also in contact with others like for
instance Francois bourgeois
Bourgeois said well I will explain you
what this Gazette I will translate you
three months of Gazette and so you have
the whole manuscript with translation of
nearly two two or three months of the
cassette from the beginning to the end
it only leaves out the name list of all
the people who were appointed and you
can find it in the Bible thickness in
the France it was not published but
again it shows how much information
about the cassette that was sent to
Europe and in it you find all kind of
interesting information among others
about this Lee Chong won rebellion in
Taiwan that took place and you have a
whole discussion because Francois
Bourgeois will say yes but they are
saying that that's the information by
the the military officials but in fact
we have other information and so that's
an interesting case of distribution of
uh
um information
I come to a conclusion
so I wanted on the basis of the cassette
which really started as I mentioned in
the beginning as a kind of mistake
because that was not my intention to
spend three years on the cassettes but
and when people ask me what are you
doing I say I'm reading The Gazette and
so well
um
so first I hope to have shown you that
by looking at this outside again it's
not the only way to write history
that also this European gazette's
sources can expand the knowledge about
what was the Gazette in the 18th century
and that this is also a nice case of
this interconnected history not only by
the fact that they write about the
Gazette how they used to get set as
Europeans but also how it circulated in
Europe and also wasn't inspiration for a
number of people
for development of their own IDs not
only about China but mainly about
political ideas for Europe
um so we can conclude that already in
the 18th century the Chinese cassette
joined in one way or another Global
public
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much for the very
informative presentation my question is
during the course of your research did
you happen to could you say more about
the printing process because the locus
of my inquiry is based on this premise
that if there was a freedom of press
then were there any private presses that
exist during that time period thank you
well I I would not uh join completely
the freedom of press
in the sense that uh what is said there
about the freedom of press and the
circulation of Knowle of uh of let's say
of information
uh as you you can see what I was talking
about is the cassette which is to a
large extent an official
document
and you have the let's say the decisions
that are taken in the palace
on the basis of this decision they make
a selection of what would be made public
and for different reasons because they
think that it's important that the
decision is known but also that is true
as a kind of instruction because it can
have a precedent in decision making
and then this was copied and then it was
printed and then in terms of printing
technique this well this were mobile
characters and for some there is a whole
discussion was it
um mobile characters in wood or the Tito
Tran Lu for some Scholars this one this
was in wax in wax where you can carve
quicker but then it's it's also a block
and then this was sent to the provinces
and there again there were republished
or redistributed and sometimes also by
by let's say 100 so that is is the
system of this Gazette so this is not
I would say completely a freedom of the
press but we understand by freedom of
the press on the other hand
you had in China
the publications of books
and there was unlike in Europe there was
no pre-printing
censorship
in Europe in the certainly in the 17th
century later on even later on you
wanted to publish a book you needed the
permission of the church and of the
state and of or of both
and you see that in all the text that it
is mentioned you have
nothing really similar to that in China
of course there could be post printing
prohibition of the of the text so these
are in fact different matters
but I quoted that because
they on the basis of The Gazette whether
what they write about the Gazette is
true or false but this gave an
inspiration to develop an own ID that's
that's what we see what happens with
with this knowledge and that can be
interpreted in different ways we can say
well they just fantasize about China or
they are see no files or you can also
say but that is sometimes say is yeah
but look how this creates new knowledge
and that is
to a certain extent disconnected from
the original meaning but that's that
happens with so many of the things that
we invent or write that this kind of
circulation happens
well thanks thanks for that Nicholas
that was really great
um and I laughed seeing the full tear
quote where he talks about how everyone
thinks the Gazette is free
um and also true because in the 1620s no
Chinese reader or a missionary reader
really trusted the gazettes because it
was full of pre-imperial review material
which gets to the point that this is a
very Dynamic genre that by the yongjun
rain is also perfectly suited to now
re-representing the state as a form of
sort of Auto propaganda even as the
contents are true and useful to
governance and so my question for you is
to think about
what the actual function of the Gazette
is for European readers
when the producer sees this as a tool
that also produces propaganda whereas in
Europe they're actually reflecting back
that propaganda almost perfectly so how
should we understand
early modern Global power relations if
we in this broader context think about
the ways Europeans were consuming
Chinese propaganda and the Chinese
vision of itself which we've
represpectively called synophilia when
in fact that's just the way Chinese
texts talk about themselves too
yeah you have a very interesting and
Broad question so first uh under the
jungjung and that's why I think Perroni
is interesting because he's a bit more
critical because he would say and give
very concrete examples there is a flood
somewhere
and he will see yeah but uh that is
reported by the officials but that does
not represent the reality and so you you
see the the conflict that is there that
this is an interpretation and that this
is not just or let's say that it is a
propaganda by the state
but you have perronis a more articulated
view on it
unfortunately it was not Peroni sticks
that were published and so what was
published is uh is
a Content sales vision
and indeed there you have the the
the
criticism that the missionaries give
towards the newspapers in Europe and
that then the contrast with China where
everything seems to be beautiful because
finally you have something that is
official in which they trust and that
can be used for instruction information
of officials
and the way in which the people let's
say thinkers reacted on that yeah there
you have again a wide variety of
reactions so but it's in a certain way
it suited some of the opinions in Europe
also
thank you sorry uh
the Hume is a occasion for us to think
about the past and the history of
Synology and listening to you speak I
was of course thinking about Jonathan
Spence and how much he would have
enjoyed your lecture uh I do have one
question for you which is not knowing
anything at all about the Gazette the
um you're you've found all this
information in the 18th century does
that information change our overall view
of The Gazette
um going through to the 19th century the
I do not really dare to say it so much
because in the end yeah I was I didn't
want to write a book on the cassette as
a whole and you have for instance the
book by Moka Russell who has the much
broader view so I didn't want to
to enter completely into that kind of
discussion but there are certainly
differences with the
19th century
because the circulation of the cassette
is much more widely
that are this is one of the aspects but
also yeah what is what was the
circulation in the seventh in the 17th
century also and we were discussing that
earlier yeah we know relatively
little about
um
about the late Ming
but
when I look at the missionary sources
yeah you your
quite
convinced that they really used this
kind of sources because when they write
and they they every year they write an
annual letter
and they write first always uh in the
beginning of the letter a state of the
art of the country and then they have
and then Christianity and then they have
the provinces and something about the
province and then Christianity in the
province now when you look at all this
information you simply wonder where did
they got it this was not ghost let's say
was not oral information it's so
detailed that it must have been based on
this on these sources but they were also
digested because they make a kind of
synthesis
um
but
yeah the structure at least the
structure of the Gazette changes to a
certain extent also in the 19th century
and you you see some
differences in the in the structure of
it but I I didn't want to to get
involved too much in the 19th century
because that's not my my my field so
yeah thank you for your question yeah
thank you very much I really loved this
topic I just learned a lot it was so
much fun
um so I remember a little about this
period but I do know that this wasn't
the only these are the only translations
that were happening in this period right
and it might even be fair to say that
the first wave of translations of
Chinese texts into Europe were
translations of the Chinese Classics
other four books and things like that
maybe just a little bit earlier than
experience so I'm wondering could you
take a step back and just reflect on the
place of these translations of gazettes
um compared within this larger universe
so translations of Chinese texts well
there's certain kinds of audiences that
are more focused on the gazettes are
there other kinds of audiences that are
more focused on let's call it Confucius
stuff
because that is maybe the first wave of
translations is there is there a
competition in Europe sort of to decide
you know which sorts of texts are going
to determine really the image of China
who are the players or their audiences
the sub audiences like what is what is
the larger scene and how does this talk
fit into that or sense of that works and
so
um
first we can say that the translations
translations
started relatively late
because
with a few exceptions but you have the
Confucius in our philosophies which is
so that's uh 1689
yeah Matthew Richie arrived in China in
1582 so that's about 100 years later
so in which they make and that's thanks
to the Exile in Canton they are together
and they really make a translation of
these basic classics
now
um
this the the time let's say shift is
1688 because
comes back to Europe and who edited the
conversation and it goes to Paris
and it meets the people of the
um of the academy academy
and there this academicians say we need
more information about China and they
have this enormous list
of what they want to know what about
history what about the origin of the of
the characters what about zoology botany
all these questions
and so then the French missionaries will
go to China
they are not sent by Rome not to
Portugal but from France
and they go to to China and that starts
yeah this is a shift from the
Renaissance to more yeah pre-modernity
Scholars
and in the beginning they are active
missionaries and they start to do some
translations but then in 1724
basically you have an expulsion
and they are confined in paid in Peking
and they will be less it will be less
possible to produce like Richie and all
these people text in Chinese
and there you see a shift also through
the better communication and because
you're the travel of documents and so on
is less Long uh where there is this uh
yeah still under
um
Petersburg painting and in Paris and
they correspond and they start to
discuss chronology or they continue to
discuss chronology and botany and so on
and so and so from that time onwards you
have a kind of systematic systematic
attempt to solve all the questions that
they got her and that is a shift because
the efforts of these missionaries and
translations
will be more devoted to translating
Chinese sticks to Europe then European
takes to Chinese
and uh was there was that adapted to
public that was partly adapted to a
public but in the first place of
academicians so they were in contact
some with astronomy and the chronology
but yeah sibo so that is
zoology and all this kind of
text
and then you have the major efforts by
duhalda in fact who says yes send me uh
I I don't have anything about
Moral Moral philosophy and then he has a
text about moral philosophy and so on so
it becomes a major Enterprise and which
is still striking because if you simply
look at the we have it on our database
also
all the texts that were translated many
of these texts are still we don't have a
Modern English French German or whatever
translation of all these texts which are
original Chinese text or by very
well-known authors but also by by rather
unknown
others recently I you had in this
description of the lashing you have the
book by Lorde who identified nearly all
the text there were five left three were
then identified in the last few years
and I discovered now the last two texts
on moral philosophy and these are
Chinese chanchu but by authors that we
have never heard and what is interesting
is that then they illuminate the
circulation of certain texts in China
because they were translated and used by
missionaries because how it how did it
work is relatively easy you want to know
something about moral philosophy you ask
a Chinese scholar what do you what is a
good book and he said so in my desk I
have this book yeah you should translate
this and that's how it works yeah
thank you as an anthropologist I am not
tuned to changes in time so I know I I'm
you know I would like to ask a question
that's quite different from my historian
colleagues
um I just want you know your your idea
of China as a concept intrigues me you
know I kind of like to have you to to
see if you can clarify your idea of how
you define China in that historical
context and the missionaries perception
of China
and then of course the European uh
Scholars concept of China and how they
differ because I was also noticing that
quite a bit of the activities were
happening in Canton
and at least you know in the period
you're you're treating and I just wonder
how these people's conception of the
country might be shaped by very Regional
context
that they found themselves in so I just
want to get a sense of this kind of
regional ethnic
you know
um you know ecological even uh diversity
of this entity we call China and how
that affects the way that we would think
about
um the cassettes and then also their
translations
yeah thank you very much it's also a
very large question I happen to write
even articles about the concept of China
in all these missionary texts but to be
very brief
um it is still China it is Ming or it is
and they adopt in the first place the
auto definition by China because when
you look at Chinese maps of that time
they will never write China
because if you have no Authority you as
a Belgium and if you only have a Belgian
map you don't have to put Belgium
because you only put Belgium when when
you have other countries around
what they will write is mean
Ming is the Ming Dynasty because you
your Authority is a former Dynasty
and there it is chain now the Ching is
not only what we call China or Han it's
also the manchus so in these texts but I
didn't develop it in my book I have a
few pages on that because for the
missionaries they when they communicate
with the emperor most often this is in
Manchu and not in Chinese they use
Mental sources also
they even refer to some possible Manchu
gazettes uh
and uh so that's one of the
differentiations and ethnic
differentiation because yeah the the
these are the the the empress but the
Emperors are emperor of the Hun and the
Mongols and of the Tibetans and and and
and the Chinese and and and the Mantra
so so it's it there is already this kind
of ethnic if we we have to be prudent
with all these words transforming at
that time
um and then
um but that's less true for uh the
information I have about
um
let's say the um uh I'm your time the
missionaries are all only in Beijing and
that's
I would say the diet link because that's
two kilometers further it's produced and
you have your own newspaper in Canton
it's different because they get also
information from the prophecies so the
the provincial newspapers that's on the
kangshi period there is a whole uh yeah
the best information about the tanchon
earthquake is by the missionaries and
not by the Chinese sources and they base
themselves on the information from the
different regions so these are kind of
indices where I would say yeah I really
agree
in this differentiation uh but yeah when
you give a presentation you cannot do
all every term so yeah
continuing the conversation upstairs in
a reception so feel free to come and to
ask any further questions upstairs over
a drink and something to eat but I did
want to thank very much our speaker
today for that really fascinating and
interesting talk I forgot in my
introduction to point out how meticulous
his scholarship is and what a range it
covers but we've seen that today in
abundance so thank you very much I think
it's given everybody something
um just the discussions and our thoughts
about modern China and the relationships
between the French Singularity and China
for example or the fact that everyone
was better informed about China in the
mid-18th century uh fascinating for us
to think about contemporary politics so
thank you very much for such a superb
talk
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you